أصدقائي الأعزاء ، لقد نجوت من كل شيء مر
من خلال كل هذه التجارب
قاتل من أجل الشرف الرياضي لروسيا و
كما قلت ، قاتلوا بكرامة
أعطى المشجعين الفرح لنا جميعًا
يرتدي أولمبياد طوكيو بشكل مقنع
أكد الخاص بك دون قيد أو شرط وعلى الصعيد العالمي
القيادة وفي نفس الوقت
خلافة أفضل محلية
تقاليد تربية الابطال في المدينة
وسام طوكيو من ألكسندر نيفسكي
منحت
مرسوم صادر عن رئيس الاتحاد الروسي
سوف تفوز الإنجازات الرياضية
المثابرة والتركيز
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
أصلا البكاء والغناء لم يكن دائما
السؤال هل تبكي في مثل هذه اللحظات أنا
أرى أن هذا يمس كثيرين ، لكنهم
تمسك ، بما في ذلك أنت
أنا بكيت
ماذا يريد أن يقول
كان الكثير ضدنا لكن الروح الروسية
من العوائق تزداد قوة
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]